طالما ساعه ايران لتمديد نفوذها السياسي
في سوريا لتعلن اليوم اسرائيل عن افشال
مخطط طهران في سوريا رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي اكد ان السلاح النووي الايراني
هو اكبر تهديدا محتمل اقليميا وعالميا
قائلا ان التصدي لايران يجب ان يشمل كل
وكلائها وانشطتها في الشرق الاوسط مضيفا
جاهزون لتنفيذ اي اوامر للتصدي لنوويه
ايران
افشلنا محاولات ايران لنصب صواريخ في
سوريا وانشاء تنظيم اشبه بحزب الله في
الجولان
وتابع هذا المخطط لم يختفي بالكامل ولدينا
المزيد مما يجب فعله في هذا الشهر
[موسيقى]
ستتغير عمليه صنع القرار بالكامل لجميع
اللاعبين في العالم تماما بمجرد ان تمتلك
ايران سلاحا نوويا للاغراض العسكريه لقد
تحسن مستوى استعداد ايران لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي جاهز لاي اوامر ضد نووي ايران
وسيلتزم بالمهام الموكله اليه وقمنا
بالفعل باحباط مخطط ايران لنشر مئات
الصواريخ في سوريا ولدينا المزيد مما
سنفعله